mais ça ya plus de dix jours avant le
premier tour achats durables oui l
affaire macky nzay prendre l'ampleur
forçant l'équipe macron a multiplié les
explications alors je vous rappelle
l'histoire un rapport du sénat publié à
la mi mars a pointé du doigt le recours
croissant par l'état des prestataires
privés et notamment donc au cabinet
mckinsey pour le guider dans son action
plus d'un milliard d'euros ont été
dépensés en 2021 maquilleuse et n'a par
ailleurs pas payé par dans aucun impôt
sur les sociétés en france entre 2011 et
2020 grâce à de l'optimisation fiscale
alors l'opposition évidemment crient au
scandale toutes les réactions sont dans
le récap politique de florent rodo et
lucile à tous
c'est l'histoire d'un caillou dans la
chaussure du président-candidat mckinsey
1 milliard un milliard c'est un vrai
scandale d'état ils ne payent pas
d'impôts il ya des zones dont je trouve
ça scandaleux vous voyez le cabinet
américain de conseil mckinsey touche des
millions d'euros de la part du
gouvernement français des contrats en
très forte hausse où emmanuel macron
ajoutez à celà zéro centime d'impôt sur
les sociétés pays en france cocktail
explosif l'occasion est trop belle pour
les opposants
en gros des gens qui prennent votre
monde pour vous donner l'heure qui font
de beaux powerpoint qui essayent de vous
montrer comment on peut faire mieux avec
moi et alors en réalité le contribuable
dans cette affaire se fait plumer trois
fois cédé contrat extrêmement onéreux
deuxièmement ces gens ne payent pas
d'impôts en tout cas pour ce qui est de
mckinsey et troisièmement souvent leur
conseil serve à faire baisser la
protection sociale et les services
publics réforme des retraites de
l'éducation nationale ou encore baisse
des allocations logement le cabinet
oeuvre contre les intérêts des français
selon anne hidalgo pour organiser les
choses non il a préféré aller chercher
un cabinet privé on ne sait pas vraiment
à quoi ça a servi mais en tous les cas
nous on n'a pas vu la couleur ni même
les effets positifs
plusieurs cadres du parti présidentiel
sont des anciens de makeen c'est du
copinage dit nathalie arthaud qui arrose
est en fait un certain nombre de gens
qu'on connaît bien ea qui y voit là on
va leur donner des petits marchés parce
qu'il ya tout ça aussi cesser de la
connivence et de la ce et c'est tout un
monde qui qui parasite en réalité qui
parasitent le budget de l'état je
demande aux parquets financiers d'ouvrir
une enquête mais on est dans quelle
démocratie cette affaire était étouffé
le président candidat se justifie ce
sont les crises notamment celle du co
vide qui sont à l'origine de ce budget
conseil en hausse
quand on veut accélérer aller très vite
et très fort sur une politique il faut
parfois avoir recours à des prestataires
extérieurs à l'état je ne vais pas moi
justifier de chaque contrat je ne
connais pas et ben moi qui les ai
passées voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve demain
voilà pour les réactions alors scandale
d'état ou fausse polémique dans la
dernière ligne droite avant le premier
tour ont fait le point ce soir avec
karine h à bouvron soir karina est ce
qu'il ya matière à un véritable mckinsey
gates écoutez rien de comparable avec le
pénélope gate les soupçons d'emplois
fictifs de l'épousé de françois fillon
en 2017 ou encore les diamants offerts
par bokassa valéry giscard d'estaing en
1981 des affaires qui leur avait été à
tous deux fatal mais il est vrai que
depuis deux semaines depuis la
publication de ce rapport sénatorial
cette affaire enfle dépasse le cadre des
simples réseaux sociaux et commence à
être prise très au sérieux par les
proches et par le président-candidat on
l'a vu hier deux de ses ministres
comptes publics et fonction publique
sont montés au créneau de clamer que
tout cela est légal qu'il n'y a rien
d'illégal qu'ils ont bien respecté les
règles de la commande publique mais il
est vrai que bien ce chiffrage il a
augmenté on parle de plus d'un milliard
d'euros l'an passé et c'est un chiffre
minimum car les sénateurs n'ont pas eu
accès à toutes les prestations de toutes
les agences étatiques et et
gouvernementales et donc il est
difficile dans ces conditions d'établir
des comparaisons avec des pays voisins
ou avec les présidents précédents mais
en ce qui concerne uniquement
maquilleuse et on a dit que c'était un
pour cent de tout c'est de toutes ses
commandes ce qui est important aussi
souligner c'est que maclean's a été
associé à bon nombre de chantiers clé de
ce quinquennat que ce soit la crise la
gestion de la crise de covin 19 ou
encore la préparation de réforme
importante comme à la réforme des
retraites ou encore celle de l'assurance
chômage ou encore vous savez toute cette
réflexion autour du rôle futur de
l'enseignant qui devait donner lieu à un
colloque qui n'agissent tu ne sais
jamais tenues et là ça pose la question
du rapport qualité prix de l'efficacité
de l'efficience enchère à ces cabinets
de consulting et puis peut-être aussi
aux non recours aux hauts fonctionnaires
français qui sont pourtant réputés être
de très bonne qualité et le tout dans un
contexte budgétaire extrêmement
contraint sa quelconque l impact sur la
campagne des manuels macron alors
effectivement ça tombe très mal puisque
ça renforce son lit de son image de
président des riches de président de la
start up nation ancien banquier
d'affaires lui-même qui d'ailleurs
compter plusieurs consultants de
mckinsey dans son cabinet lorsqu'il
était à bercy qu'il avait épaulé lors de
sa campagne de 2017 et non certains
d'ailleurs figure en bonne place au sein
du parti présidentiel alors le
gouvernement a promis un de mettre en
place de nouvelles règles déontologiques
pour encadrer mieux ces cabinets de
conseil sur l'attribution des marchés ou
encore sur la publication de leurs
prestations c'est un premier pas vers
plus de transparence qui est nécessaire
voire peut être indispensable pour ne
serait-ce que pouvoir évaluer
l'influencé réelle de ces cabinets
privés dans la sphère publique merci
beaucoup karina pour cet éclairage donc
sur la ferme à kinsale et la macro ni
elle sonne la mobilisation générale face
à la menace le pen oui on en parlait
hier raphaël l'écart s'est fortement
resserré ces derniers jours entre le
président sortant et la candidate du
rassemblement national un petit coup
d'oeil au sondage du jour selon l'ipsos
emmanuel macron est crédité de 27% des
voix contre 20% pour marine le pen 15 me
pour cent pour jean luc mélenchon en
bien ancrée en troisième position eric
zemmour est à 11 et demi pourcent
valérie pécresse 9% et puis pour les
plus petits candidats fabien roussel
notamment est à 3% deux ennemis pour
jean lassalle ou encore 2% pour anne
hidalgo et donc au second tour emmanuel
macron est crédité désormais de 54% des
voix 46 % pour la candidate du
rassemblement national emmanuel macron a
donc logiquement
concentré ses attaques aujourd'hui sur
l'extrême droite il était à fouras en
charente-maritime un déplacement durant
lequel il a aussi défendu son bilan très
mitigé on le sait en matière d'écologie
et il a affiché ses ambitions futures
pour le climat lui qui avait jusqu'ici
fait campagne à minima les précisions de
marie schuster qui étaient sur place
pour france 24
nouvelle opération séduction des manuels
macro à moins de deux semaines du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle après dijon le président
candidat s'est rendu à fouras au large
de fort boyard en charente-maritime où
il a vanté les mérites de son bilan en
matière d'environnement et présenter son
programme pour les cinq années à venir
un constat contrastée pour les habitants
de fouras que nous avons rencontrés et
qui ont pu échanger avec lui
socialement écologiquement c'est c'est
une catastrophe et pathétique et on est
extrêmement inquiet pour l'avenir si
effectivement il est réélu alors
j'habite pas très éloigné de centrales
nucléaires je suis à 40 km et c'est vrai
j'y pense de temps en temps
c'est vrai que c'est une question très
grave l éclat mais je pense qu'en fait
on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le choix
ou alors il faut tellement changé notre
style de vie que la plupart des gens ne
l'accepterons pas au coeur de son
programme l'investissement dans le
nucléaire emmanuel macron veut sortir de
la dépendance aux hydrocarbures
nous lui avons donc posé l'épineuse
question de la gestion des déchets
nucléaires
il ya des sujets qui vont prendre du
temps mais c'est bien certain de cela
mais si on n'investit pas on engage pas
ce sera encore plus loin donc ça dépend
de l'avancée de la science et de
l'innovation technologique et je
souhaite que ce soit le plus rapide
possible sous mes pieds l'ancienne
déchetterie de prémat news repose 19
mille mètres cubes de déchets enfouis et
charrié par la mer emmanuel macron a
promis plus de 3 millions d'euros pour
assainir ce site
les travaux débuteront à la fin de
l'année mais pour se débarrasser de ses
déchets domestiques qui se déversent
chaque jour dans l'océan il aura fallu
45 ans et on va maintenant s'intéresser
à la façon dont les candidats à la
présidentielle envisage des relations
entre la france et l'afrique h rennes
oui tout au long de la 5e république
raphaël les candidats à la
présidentielle accordée une véritable
place à cette question certains se
rendant même sur place pour y chercher
notamment des soutiens financiers et
c'est l'une des dérives de ce qu'on a
appelé la françafrique aujourd'hui cette
page semble tournée laissant place à une
forme d'indifférence de la part des
candidats on en parle ce soir avec
virgin hier soir virginie rares sont
ceux qui ont te disons une véritable
vision des relations que doivent
entretenir la france et l'afrique en
tout cas le thème de l'immigration est
souvent mise en avant et c'est notamment
le cas on le sait d'eric zemmour oui
c'est un lieu ça a donné lieu presque un
incident diplomatique avec le sénégal
c'était il ya quelques jours eric
zemmour se rendrait dans le quartier
parisien de la villette où il est
interpellé par un habitant qui raconte
son ras-le-bol face aux consommateurs et
aux revendeurs de crack le candidat de
reconquête rétorque alors qu'il faut
renvoyer tous les étrangers et tous les
trafiquants et prétend que la plupart
des trafiquants je le cite sont
sénégalais clandestins et qui n'ont rien
à faire ici alors la réponse des
autorités sénégalaises et de l'ambassade
du sénégal en particulier ne s'est pas
fait attendre dès le lendemain sur
twitter notamment où on pouvait voir un
communiqué qui dénonçaient les propos je
cite d'un racisme primaire incontestable
qui relève d'une stigmatisation
injurieuses portant gravement atteinte à
l'honorabilité de toute une communauté
sénégalaise et qui pointe elle un
acharnement obsessionnel de monsieur
zemmour contre le sénégal et sa
communauté établie en france pour rappel
effectivement en mai dernier déjà eric
zemmour sur une chaîne prix et avait
déjà prétendu que tous les trafiquants
de crack étaient des sénégalaises et
sans aller aussi loin qu eric zemmour
d'autres candidats virginie de droite et
d'extrême droite aborde la politique
africaine principalement sous l'angle de
l'insécurité ou l'immigration oui
absolument leur but c'est de renforcer
les frontières et de bloquer l'arrivée
de candidats à l'émigration en
particulier non européens c'est le cas
notamment de marine le pen qui promet de
faire du contrôle de l'immigration la
priorité de son quinquennat si elle est
élue elle a tout un programme qui va de
la fin du droit du sol au fait de
déchoir de leur nationalité les
binationaux ou les personnes
naturalisées coupables de crimes la
suppression du regroupement familial
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya un
autre volet qui est celui de l'aide au
développement marine le pen veulent
augmenter à 0 7% du pib selon les
critères de l'onu pour justement inciter
les candidats à l'émigration à rester
chez eux et cette idée cette idée on la
retrouve dans le programme des
républicains notamment défendu par
valérie pécresse qui dit qu'il faut
faire de la coopération pour je cite
fixer la jeunesse africaine en afrique
une idée qu'on trouve aussi dans
programme de nicolas dupont aignan qui
parle d'un grand projet de partenariat
avec l'afrique sur son site internet qui
s'inquiètent du boom démographique à
venir et propose très concrètement
d'aider le développement de
l'agriculture africaine et d'électrifier
le continent et pendant ce temps à
gauche virginie les candidats insiste
plutôt sur un partenariat solidaire avec
l'afrique solide et avait surtout nous
insistent aussi sur le potentiel des
diasporas c'est le cas notamment de
yannick jadot qui part d'un partenariat
solidaire proche du terrain associant
les populations locales et les diasporas
yannick jadot qui au passage a passé 18
mois au burkina façon tant
qu'humanitaires après ses études vous
avez aussi anne hidalgo qui dit que la
diaspora est un atout pour la politique
française de développement mais qui met
en garde contre le risque de vider les
pays de leur talent leur plus à gauche
vous avez selon une lecture
anticapitaliste nathalie arthaud ou
encore philippe poutou qui eux estiment
que la pauvreté est entretenu par les
politiques colonialistes qu'il faut
cesser le soutien aux dictatures
africaines et mettre fin totalement à la
présence militaire française en afrique
c'est une vision qui partageait pas luc
mélenchon qui lui souhaitent une
relation france-afrique base et je cite
sur la souveraineté des peuples et des
noms sur le site encore la politique
pourrie d'emmanuel macron et sa vision
affairistes qui répond seul intérêt
bornes et des oligarchies emmanuel
macron lui qui de son côté veut
poursuivre dit il la refondation des
relations france afrique qui ont marqué
son premier quinquennat par plusieurs
geste très symbolique comme par exemple
la restitution des oeuvres d'art au
bénin mais dans la politique africaine
est aussi critiquée par certains parce
qu'elle s'est traduit par une perte
d'influencé de la france en afrique face
notamment à la russie à la turquie et à
la chine merci beaucoup virginie on vous
retrouve donc jeudi prochain point un
autre décryptage et c'est déjà la forte
de france 2022 l'heure du choix vous
demain à cherré la même heure pour
france 2022 l'heure du choix non se
retrouve dans trois minutes maintenant
pour un nouveau journal dans parisien
[Musique]